foreign
how has the pandemic force you to
redefine success in the restaurant
industry well I think I defined success
would you say your Palestinian Roots
gave you the refugee resilience to make
so many pivots these last few years well
I really wouldn't put it quite like that
I mean really kind of being Palestinian
I don't like being called chef
chefs are bosses they just want you to
fear them
the only thing I've ever done to scare
my workers is breastfeed in the kitchen
[Applause]
[Music]
I didn't even want a restaurant I just
wanted my minutia to give the pizza a
run for its money
my greatest joy is hitting dough and I
hella need dough right now so it would
be easy if I was a trust fund baby like
those famous white chefs on Netflix
must be nice not having to be a bread
maker and a breadwinner all at the same
time not having to deal with violent
threats for being who you are a
Palestinian woman who dares to speak the
truth yeah that always goes well in
America
but here I am right I must have tricked
all these fancy foodie writers or
something now they've got me all up in
this weird-ass world of VIP chefs and
all this hype but for who
I'm nothing without these folks
we're out of summer squash what do you
want us to use instead
um what do we have on hand
[ __ ] it's summer we could grow some corn
throw in some Cotija Crema cilantro in
there a couple of jalapenos boom you got
an elote my new shape perfect I'll throw
something back on it heard that
foreign
how come we're around food all day long
but restaurant workers are some of the
hungriest people I know I mean how was
Tomas supposed to feed his kids off of
eight bucks an hour at his last job he
barely had enough to feed himself and
Kendra she worked 10 years without a
single sick day because her famous
Michelin star Chef didn't know how to
run in his kitchen without her
I try to make sure that never happens
here
but I'm not gonna lie that [ __ ] is hard
foreign
how do you pay everyone well without
pricing out your own people especially
when your landlord keeps raising the
rent on you like you're some millionaire
techie
from the outside everyone thinks that
we're all good that I'm all good what am
I supposed to say that I'm miserable
that I feel alone working 16 hour days
getting oven burns up and down my body
while my baby boy hardly knows me
everyone keeps calling me a success but
I feel like a failure
foreign
when the virus hit they just left us out
here exposed to die like The Hunger
Games and for what to be stuck on a
gerbil wheel going nowhere the virus
didn't kill me but this industry almost
did
I can't go back to how things were
before
I won't
come on you can't be late to the big
ball who knows
please
foreign
the prestigious chefs Institute of
America
finally a Palestinian infiltrating the
CIA
she is a visionary a culinary connector
on behalf of the board and with a
special thanks to our corporate sponsor
doordash I am proud to present this
year's Rising Star chef of the Year
award tarim aseel
[Music]
people like to call the chef a culinary
wizard
who makes magic in the kitchen all by
himself
well I've been behind that curtain and
I've seen Oz with my own two eyes
I'm here to tell you
he's a [ __ ] imposter
stop making me the token Brown woman for
your American Dream foodie fantasy
you all want to make me the hero of this
story but you don't even know who the
villain is do you
speaking of which
shout out to doordash in the building I
see you out here making us restaurants
dependent on you when you make billions
of dollars off our backs I've been in an
abusive relationship before I know one
when I see it and what up big restaurant
corporations you got a small business
owners pitted against our workers when
really all we're just fighting for our
crumbs meanwhile you got the big boys at
Shake Shack and PF Chang's taking all
the PPP money hugging the whole [ __ ]
pie I mean [ __ ] I bake pies pie is meant
to be shared
so you want to redefine success in the
restaurant industry well so do I
we're going to be a worker on Co-op no
more Almighty chefs no more [ __ ]
now if you'll excuse me I gotta go
my co-owners are working on a recipe
from halabia custard that puts your
creme brulee to [ __ ] shame
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]